[Music]
in money-hungry news submitted by sexual
healing
thank you appearing a man is suing a Las
Vegas hotel after fleeing from a
life-size mannequin in his room that
money I don't understand what this all
happened and Planet Hollywood I've never
been inside that used to be the Aladdin
I think I can so tired walk around Vegas
I just stick to the hotel amount or the
ones rounding I'm going to explore more
of them that's what I used to do back in
a day from 18 till maybe 22 my favorite
thing to do was walk up and down the
strip because I couldn't spend money
their fathers or what they look yeah it
feels right doesn't the one right over
you could spend the whole day just going
on one side of the strip Planet
Hollywood decorated their rooms with
memorabilia and so currently this
specific room that this man walked into
so he walked into his darkened hotel
room which on my crunchity sternum like
I said it's not easy to find it I
immediately turn on the down life so in
his room there was a men a life-sized
mannequin wearing a Miller Lite racing
suit that was locked in a glass cabinet
in his room as creepiest cabinet as in
it's a display case yes that is not
scary at all then that's [ __ ] bitter
display case he thought someone was in
his room trying to hurt him so
immediately once you saw the mannequin
he ran out all these people think
they're so special maybe he's really
rich it could be a [ __ ] Polish sweet
I don't know if you are a baller Swede
and you're going to plan on it was a lot
of but better place is gonna have two
ballers don't go to plan a Holloway you
saying that as he fled he suffered a lot
of injuries the carpet just destroyed
its feet that's some big [ __ ] seriously
yeah she [ __ ] ran into the hallway
and all that cold no thank you
how could when he ran to the hallway he
[ __ ] ran into the wall with his face
I get it like who runs like that you
look clumsy [ __ ]
the lawsuit claimed that he suffered
undefined injuries to his body limbs
organs mind and nervous system
and so it's resulting in a conditions
that may be permanent and disabling oh
my god this sounds we're going to be
easy agent is a big stuff yeah why would
you declare to the world that you're up
there I know which already not hurt
though it's [ __ ] I know your name lien
well it's can't Jacobs about well agent
who don't do not know for suing like
that true all that's right you're not a
[ __ ] and you got scared just keep that
[ __ ] to yourself Asian people are known
to be a [ __ ] sometimes but they don't
care so this man he's seeking at least
and you are such a [ __ ] I think he
was just like overly drunk and when he
got into his room he just not even that
this guy I want to see his history of
how many times he sued institutions Yeah
right because there's people like that
who constantly sue
once you're there enough of that Oh suey
I've heard of people like they'll bring
like water bottles through grocery or
the grocery store and they kind of spray
a little bit and then wait a little bit
and then they'll come back around and
they'll slip on it that's why we have
that's why we always have CCTV
everywhere at all times
even at the the new place that I have
right now we have a CVT everywhere you
cannot say you did something or
something happened without us knowing
that we're calling 24 [ __ ] Center
said yeah because people people try
stupid [ __ ] like that all the [ __ ]
time and it's also for the safety of our
employees as well
I hope somebody like pours water and
when they want to calm the place and
then they slip and actually break their
[ __ ] head at night everybody just
wants a [ __ ] freedom and like why
just [ __ ] spend your time those would
be more productive man I would be
embarrassed dude like I wouldn't have
the [ __ ] nerve to sue a place if I'm
if if I saw manikin in my room and I ran
out the frickin door and started like
hitting the walls like oh I [ __ ] be
embarrassed dude because they're gonna
have to watch the footage bring it up to
court and you see me going like like
[ __ ] it turning on the light
[ __ ] like hitting the wall thank you
I think you have your Milani holy [ __ ]
you're like yeah I can't be proud of
that how I don't know [ __ ] embarrass
like [ __ ] I don't want nobody no keep
that [ __ ] to yourself yeah I got too
much pride man I [ __ ] that isn't
that's the same reason like guys will
never ever say that they guys like rape
or something because of the shame that
comes out of it or they get like
sexually harassed 'ok that domestic
why's what i'm sorry like domestic
violence right that's why they won't
ever say because like a shame to it but
there's some guys that are just straight
[ __ ] and they Gendo like [ __ ] try
to sue a supermarket for water on the
back 100 percent of a woman raped me i'm
not saying [ __ ] i would let a woman
overpowered me like somebody half my
size
hey Raylan no I'm okay sometimes our
street cred is more important sometimes
you've got to take the l-sit why you
would be David [ __ ] jelly do I
Mexican food and a hot diarrhea okay you
guys be the first person to know if I
get raped by a woman we are gonna brag
no it's not rape if I'm if I'm enjoying
it like it or you want yeah [ __ ] grab
me by the balls and start twisting and
twisting and twisting it like it's a
[ __ ] like oil change and [ __ ] oh the
article we did back in the day which one
the Russian lady who had the hair salon
Oh about that he said the dude viagra
everyday look at Dakota she [ __ ] him
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of him yeah she was
great she literally raped him I never
even thought that women could give
somebody viagra to force an erection
just bounce on that dick genius and it's
genius that she gave him money and some
jeans when she kicked them out I'm done
with your dick all right that guy was a
robbery she [ __ ] his ass up he came into
the shop and you wanted he wanted to rob
her so he threatened her life and she's
like no no hey you're kind of cute I'm
gonna keep you for my little [ __ ]
dick patch you look up martial artists
of some sort yeah and then she tied in
love with like her hair dryer cords
mm-hmm
no double standard for me I think that's
amazing
it is didn't have any clients for the
next few days because I feel like if you
enter someone's property willing to
commit a crime then the law doesn't
really affect you anymore so once you
get it's like oh so you're going to
commit a crime now it's my rule
my land and it just so happens that the
criminal that came into my house also
has a pretty face guess what I'm gonna
do I'm a [ __ ] suing in lawsuits are
absolutely insane man
I don't know if I've never sued somebody
before I don't know what that feels so
you how badly do I have to feel was it
called how much of an injustice do I
have to feel that when you become an
adult you're not supposed to fist fight
so that's why you sue people nothing you
got into a fistfight huh dude that's a
long time ago dude come on now we're all
older now cuz I'm pretty sure like
cereal come on guys well I honestly feel
like if I did get into a fistfight
nowadays most likely I'm going to lose
okay because I don't have a mentality to
hurt myself in order to be gun ready for
that [ __ ] because I think also to like
when everybody else around you is like
in that type of environment you're
already kind of ready I only want to
fight for sport not out of anger
I don't even think I like this I didn't
want this I got geologists like I'm
trying to live my life and have a good
time but there is this 1% part of me
well I'm like this is the strongest I've
ever been in my entire life I wonder
what that feels like into grabbing
another human being I feel like you
wouldn't really Biss fight you would
just try to tear limbs off an experiment
what would happen if I grabbed his ears
and what I like this one yeah
take your hand in a nothing ah you
remember the last time you touched
somebody in the face yeah all the last
time I was with Joe and now we fought
like these three thousand five and I
punched somebody in the face and my
knuckle just Mike what is this index
finger ring finger popped out of my
knuckles this is a little Tokyo hole we
were 23 yeah we were 23 so now you're
the strongest you've ever been in your
lives some [ __ ] goes down possibility of
getting into a fight if they catch me
off guard if I'm regular level-headed
the way I usually have I'm an I'm so
sorry I don't want any trouble like
let's just leave whatever we can solve
this raging doesn't count by the way
because I'm more likely to fight during
the time of Rage but like let's say me
no general argument and there's someone
[ __ ] with me and I'm not level-headed
deaden yes let's entertain that what
what happened I guess I'm wondering like
would you rather this site or sue I
don't like things that have this huge
like lingering effect you know like for
me it's like which is beat each other's
ass I kick your ass or you kick my ass
over and done with move on with life I
don't wanna have to deal with this
lingering like I got email and I hate
[ __ ] baggage and residual [ __ ] I
think that's why we like Hawaii because
you can also get food from that man that
you view that means you didn't do a good
job 22nd birthday that's the last time
on your birthday that's a birthday
promise that this lady will we used to
call her mama when being [ __ ] up a
lady oh [ __ ] it was at this lady's house
called mama one day she was kind of cool
because she lives like she I didn't
smoke but everybody that smoke and drink
at her place and it was like kind of at
a farm area in Sacramento so Sacramento
if you guys haven't been there it's
there's a lot of fields a lot of open
area people owned a lot of land
so mama when they used to like grow like
not that was the people no she used to
grow like sativa and [ __ ] like that so
people were smoking out and then you
know it was a relatively big party was
my birthday a couple of other people
have birthdays in March and then people
tried to come into the party and if you
don't know them we don't want you there
right so we're like leave [ __ ] got out
of hand
everybody got to a big brawl from Mel's
lost anyone up not really though it's
hard to fight when there's like a whole
bunch of people on to confusion going on
and in like how the people are just
drunk and then touching your own friends
and stuff about asking you I end up
punching your own friends no see this is
kind of weird because like I remember
that situation because I was just
chilling in the backside and all of them
are physically goes Joe is going down
and like all right because everybody got
up and I just it was just a brawl I got
kicked him in the face during that fight
with me and bar from my own friend the
biggest damage that I got I had a
freaking like big scratch across my
cheek was from my own friend cracked
what the [ __ ] is nails worth on Chris
kicked them I have tissue how do you
kick you did he like no you know I was
going down like this on three of them I
think he was aiming for the guy I was I
was throwing punches at and then his
kick missed him and it just [ __ ] hit
me in the face and then it gave him a
chance to run away
chris is testing out a really good time
during the sounds like my career I had
an awesome thing going out because we
were training at that time yeah I got to
use everybody s that I learned what I
grabbed my job
I grabbed them by the collar like it was
Agee and I grabbed and I need on my 20
times and then the other guy was on the
ground and I kicked them in the ribs and
I have really good hip broken jaw fooled
and he was probably crying for help all
right shut the [ __ ] up little [ __ ]
being with aggressive you know I'm
almost crawling on the grill yeah I
never had guys that much so great dude I
got those four by the hair smells like
poo poo oh I miss you know this but
violence is wrong guys don't [ __ ] do
that [ __ ]
it's so bad just do people that bad
don't do it it's wrong honestly like my
perfect situation would be like United
Airlines doctor down I want that [ __ ]
that happens to me so bad dude just
because I would call a book it soon
perfect cougar leg straight up give me
some [ __ ] money dude I'll tell you
right now the [ __ ] [ __ ] most likely
if you want to [ __ ] fight me I don't
fight you do I'll get a lot of cameras
I'll sue the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
I'll hope you knock out my teeth bench
McDonald sorry I can't God I'm the first
to say sorry hello my mother Joe Malians
please like the video and for more
beautiful videos look up there
[Music]